-Our next guest is
an Emmy-nominated actor
you know from
the show "Normal People"
and the film
"The Lost Daughter."
He stars in "Aftersun,"
which is in select theaters
October 21st.
Let's take a look.
-Good.
[ Billiard balls clacking ]
Well done.
♪♪
-So, what's your sister's name?
-Sophie.
-Oh, nice.
-I'm her dad, though, actually.
-Oh. Sorry, mate.
I just thought --
-That's okay.
♪♪
It's a nice hotel, eh?
-Oh, it's alright.
-Please welcome to the show,
Paul Mescal, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I'm so happy to have you here.
-Thanks very much.
-Congratulations on this film.
It's a very beautiful film about
a young father and his daughter.
And a lot of it is unsaid.
I would say that is not
a dialogue-heavy film.
When you were reading through
the script the first time,
did you appreciate exactly
how special it was going to be?
-Yeah, it's one of those scripts
that you read and you're like,
"How do I get to the top
of the pile of actors
that are going to want it?"
So, yeah, I was very aware
of the kind of -- the fact
that it was kind of nonverbal
in how it presents itself.
And, yeah, I just very quickly
auditioned for Charlie
and here I am talking about it.
-You play a young father
in the film.
You're not a young father
in real life.
And you actually took
a rehearsal vacation
with your costar.
-Yeah, Yeah. We landed in Turkey
kind of two weeks
before the shoot,
and I asked Frankie's mom
and dad if I could,
like, be her pretend dad
for two weeks.
And so, yeah, we hung out.
-We were the kind of parents
who were like, "Yep."
-They were like, "Please."
No, no, no. They were great.
Like, we swam in the sea,
ate pancakes, swam in the pool,
lots of swimming.
And we taught her
how to play pool.
-She's fantastic.
It's also her first film.
Is it -- How is it to have
a scene partner,
especially one in a -- in a film
where the connection
is so intense, who is...
I mean, I would just assume
a natural at it?
-Total natural.
It's, like, frightening.
You're like, "Whoa.
If you knew how good
you are right now,
it would be, like, shocking."
But, yeah, I feel like
with young actors
and people starting out,
you're kind of harnessing
or they're holding on
to this thing.
Whereas with older actors
you can kind of...
talk acting out of existence,
here she's just so pure
and full of life.
And it's -- Yeah, it was...
-Is it contagious?
Did you find yourself going back
to sort of the roots of, like,
what's natural about acting?
-Yeah, well,
she just surprises you.
She would do something, like,
in a scene where you're, like,
"Whoa, I wish
I thought of that."
She's just in it all the time,
and I just can't wait for people
to see her performance
in the film.
-This is an exciting time.
You're in a couple of movies
right now.
"God's Creatures," as well.
I have to ask a question,
because you are shucking oysters
a great deal in this film
very believably so.
Was that a skill you had
before you took this part?
-It was -- No, that was not
a skill that I had.
-That's a dangerous one to learn
because I feel like there's no
shortcuts with shucking oysters.
-No, there's -- there's
no shortcuts. Yeah.
Fodhla, our wonderful producer,
her brother is an oyster farmer.
So I was like,
"I'm going to be a proper actor
and learn how to do this."
And went out on the water
with John Michael
and he taught me how to do it,
yeah.
-Are you pretty good now?
-Eh, middling, yeah.
Yeah.
-Thank you for your honesty.
[ Laughter ]
I want to talk about --
you had, in early life,
a parallel track
of both acting --
You were in acting school,
but you were also playing...
I guess this isn't
technically rugby.
This is Gaelic?
-Gaelic football, yeah.
-Gaelic football?
How would you describe, for
those of us who are maybe not up
on the latest?
-Gaelic football?
-Yeah, Gaelic football.
-Chaos.
-Pure chaos.
It's basically like a mix
between rugby and soccer,
but is just...brutal.
-Yeah.
-Well, rugby is pretty brutal,
but, like, you represent
like your parish
or where you come from.
It's, like, nonprofessional.
So it's like very much like...
very spirited, I would say.
-So it's not that
there's a different rule.
It's just like people
are maybe more prone to fight?
-Yeah, yeah.
It depends on which town
you're playing against.
-Gotcha. Did you --
Did you play for a good town?
Were you guys good at it?
-Yeah. I liked my town.
[ Laughter ]
-I meant good at the sport.
Were you a nice place to live?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah, I played
for Maynooth and...
and Kildare, my county.
This is like a geography lesson.
-Gotcha.
-For anybody who doesn't know,
that's Kildare.
-Seems like mouth guard
is a pretty important
part of that I'm assuming.
-Yeah, very necessary.
-And was it --
were you prone to injury,
or do the people who
play Gaelic football get...?
-Yeah, I broke my nose
and my jaw.
I broke my jaw two days
before starting
my final year in drama school.
So I was like, "I'm going
to probably give it a break
for the last year."
I found out that they don't
really go hand-in-hand.
You can't really act
with a broken jaw.
-When you showed up to
acting school with a broken jaw,
were you honest that this
happened during Gaelic football?
-Because they say you're not
allowed to play any sport
because it's like bad
for your, like, body and stuff,
and I was like,
"Yeah, it'll be fine."
Go in, and I -- face-to-face
with my, like, acting teachers
and they're like,
"What's wrong?"
And I was like,
"Well, this is so weird.
I got mugged at work.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. A nightmare."
And so I spent the four weeks
in rehearsals
just kind of like rehearsing
like this.
Yeah, yeah.
-Was Gaelic football sad
to see you go?
Did you have a skill at it?
Were they like,
"we lost one of our good ones
to the acting craft"?
[ Laughter ]
-I hope that's what they say.
Yeah.
I hope that's what they say.
-You know,
for matters of this,
let's just all agree
that they're still talking
about you in the pubs.
The one that got away.
-Exactly. Exactly.
Yeah. Yeah.
-We were talking backstage,
you know,
because you -- "Normal People,"
which is so wonderful --
and you actually haven't done
any one of these
talk shows in person.
You did a bunch of them on Zoom
during the...
-Yeah.
-Was it --
'Cause it was one of
our first pandemic shows.
My wife and I watched it.
Was it cool
to make a show like that,
that obviously worst
possible reason
for people to connect with it,
but everybody was looking
for shows,
and I feel like that was one
a lot of people found.
-Totally and, like,
these things are wonderful,
but they're kind of stressful
a little bit.
So getting to do it
a kind of a year
further into it is fantastic.
And for it to be
"Normal People"
the thing that people
still talk about
that I'm really, really
proud of is...
I'm very grateful for that.
-Yeah, well,
it was a really special show
and it's so great
to meet you in person.
Thank you so much
for being here, Paul.
-Thanks for having me.
Thank you so much.
-Paul Mescal, everybody.
"Aftersun" is in select theaters
is October 21st,
and "God's Creatures"
is in theaters Friday.
We'll be right back to music
from 5 Seconds of Summer.